For all the answers we got at the end of Endgame,
there are still a few nagging questions that
weren't entirely summed up by the time those
credits rolled.
Some of these questions go back multiple films
in the franchise, while others were introduced
in Endgame and then seemingly abandoned.
What are we talking about?
Snap on your spoiler gloves, because we're
digging deep to find all the unanswered questions
from Avengers: Endgame.
Once again, to be clear: Spoilers ahead!
There was a lot of mantle passing in the closing
moments of Endgame, much of it in heartwarming
fashion.
Old Man Cap passing his shield on to Falcon?
It doesn't get much better than that.
We've got a more grown-up Cassie Lang in the
picture, and Clint hit a bullseye with his
daughter.
But what about Iron Man?
Who's set to replace him?
The obvious choice is, of course, little Morgan
Stark.
Her father even died in a battle with an intergalactic
wacko.
Stuff that in a box and label it "Origin Story."
But if that's the timeline the MCU is taking,
it raises the question: When is the next time
we'll see a version of Iron Man on the big
screen?
Morgan's, what, four years old?
Less than five for sure, because of the snappenings.
By the time she's old enough to strap on some
nanites, the rest of the Avengers will be
hanging up their own suits.
Months before Endgame's release, a theory
was making the rounds that Tony Stark would
make his own Infinity Gauntlet and reverse
Thanos' snap.
It didn't happen quite like that, but the
theory was pretty dang close, and it brought
up some really interesting points that we
were all hoping would get answered in Endgame.
One is the idea that Tony has been feeling
echoes across time from using the Stones.
Across several movies, Tony Stark has been
having problems with his arm.
If he had such immense power at his fingertips,
some of that power might ripple backwards
through time and give him arm problems as
far back as Captain America: Civil War.
But Infinity War brought that ripple even
closer to home.
Remember how Tony Stark had a dream that Pepper
had a baby girl and they named her Morgan?
A dream like that could have been another
echo from the future, since future Tony knew
that he had a daughter when he used the Infinity
Stones.
And its placement in the film just before
Endgame has to be more than coincidence.
"Future uses, and that's it.
Just in case there's a monster in the closet
instead of, you know…"
"Shirts."
Unfortunately, it's all still just speculation,
since Endgame never really addressed that
in any way.
Infinity War's big thing was unquestionably
the snap.
Thanos foreshadowed it, then the final battle
came and he upheld his promise, turning half
the universe to dust with a snap of his fingers.
Cinematically, it's great.
It's one instantly identifiable gesture of
annihilation that also says, "Look how easy
it is to clean up the universe."
From a comics perspective, it holds up as
well, since that's what Thanos did in Infinity
Gauntlet.
So then Endgame comes along, and the only
way to make the Stones work is now snapping.
Is that in the Infinity Manual?
When Professor Hulk put on the glove the first
time, he was clearly picturing what he wanted
to happen, since he says he also tried to
bring back Natasha.
And in the final battle, both Tony and Thanos
try snapping.
The movie never answers the question of whether
there are other ways to use all the Stones.
After all, if they're powerful enough to bring
back trillions of life forms with all their
memories and costumes intact, wouldn't just
wishing be enough without the snap?
Let's face it: Any movie dealing with time
travel is going to run into problems.
For its part, though, Endgame did wrap up
a lot of loose timelines, explain most of
what needed explaining, and keep the plot
moving.
Out of all the time travel shenanigans, one
question that was almost definitely intentionally
left unanswered was the 2012 Loki's whereabouts.
If you remember, while in the past after the
Battle of New York, Stark fumbled the Tesseract,
and Loki snagged it while no one was looking
and slipped away into a portal.
By doing so, he presumably created a different
timeline that didn't end up with that version
of himself being choked by Thanos.
So now there's a rogue Loki roaming another
timeline, but the movie leaves that guy's
fate completely unmentioned.
What kind of mischief is he getting up to
with the ability to travel anywhere in the
universe?
"I'm sorry about that thing with the Tesseract.
I just couldn't help myself."
There's a huge disconnect between the way
the Infinity Stones are built up in the previous
movies, and the way they're handled in Endgame.
Literally handled.
In Guardians of the Galaxy, the Collector
gave a whole Powerpoint presentation that
explained how only a being of extraordinary
strength can wield an Infinity Stone.
A few seconds later, his lady servant grabbed
the Power Stone and exploded to prove to audiences
that he wasn't lying.
So sure, using the stones is devastating.
But it's pretty clear what these stones can
do to you just by touching them.
Fast forward to the Endgame, though, and people
are tossing the stones around like hot potatoes.
For starters, Hulk and Hawkeye both held a
Stone in their bare hands.
Granted, those are plausible, at least.
The Hulk is, if nothing else, a being of immense
power.
And just like Thanos, Clint Barton was given
the Soul Stone in exchange for his sacrifice,
so maybe he was allowed to hold it.
Even so, it's not like the Stones in the gauntlet
are shielded by anything, and yet half the
Avengers got in on that game of keep-away
with the glove.
None of those mortals even brushed a finger
across an Infinity Stone?
None of them caught it wrong, or slapped a
palm over a Reality Stone or two?
When Peter Parker comes back during that epic
final battle, he tells Tony that he must have
"passed out," because when he woke up back
on Titan, Stark was gone.
The implication there is that time didn't
pass for the people who were dusted.
Five years went by in the real world, but
all the dust bunnies came back just thinking
they'd taken a quick nap.
It goes by pretty smoothly, mainly because
there's so much other stuff happening then,
but during the wrap-up scenes when we see
Peter back in school, reuniting with Ned,
you start to wonder: How is society going
to reconcile what happened?
It's convenient that all of Peter's friends
were apparently also dusted, so now they get
to finish going through high school together.
But what about the rest of the world?
Most of these people essentially blinked,
and Citi Field looks suddenly looks like the
apocalypse.
Little Suzy's in college.
Grandpa Joe's kidneys failed.
He's dead.
Picture that, but multiplied by billions.
The world is going to have a whole heck of
a lot of work to do fixing things up, and
Endgame didn't touch on that question at all.
Finally, the most important question of all
is, who DOES put mayo on a hot dog?
Gross.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.